[Musique]
il est venu le temps non pas des
cathédrales dans cette émission même
s'il sera question de Moyen-Âge dans un
instant mais de la première chronique en
plateau sur le plateau de TV 78 de
Gabriel Gontier ça va pas trop de
pression pour pour cette première
chronique vous allez nous parler des
idées de sortie du weekend en tout cas
votre sélection des idées de sortie du
week-end et vous commencez par le
festival de la BD de buxe un rendez-vous
classique chaque année à l'automne et ça
revient pour une 29e édition tout à fait
Grégory cette année encore le festival
accueille une cinquantaine d'auteurs
adultes jeunesse mais aussi français et
internationaux au programme du week-end
des dédicaces des rencontres avec les
auteurs des expositions et des
animations une fois encore et petits et
grands vont pouvoir retrouver leur
personnage préféré oui cette année on
retrouve Spirou les profs Yakari et bien
d'autres de quoi faire le bonheur des
passionnés de BD préféré peut-être de BD
je vous pose pas la question ce que vous
aviez déjà donné quelques éléments de
réponse mardi dans le 7 8 mais c'est
Mathilde si vous avez posé la question
donc on va lui poser la question
le personnage préféré alors moi c'est
une BD peu connue en fait ça s'appelle
Julie Clerc Cécile c'est une BD belge et
voilà c'est une BD peu connue mais que
j'adorais lire quand j'étais plus jeune
c'est l'histoire de trois jeunes femmes
donc la fête de la BD ça se passe ce
weekend du côté de Buc alors c'est tout
aussi immersif c'est à château fort
cette fois-ci avec aussi un rendez-vous
traditionnel c'est la foire médiévale
c'est ce weekend oui complètement
traditionnel on peut le dire c'est la
36e édition de la foire de château fort
en immersion les visiteurs seront
projetés des siècles en arrière pour
retrouver l'ambiance du Moyen-Âge avec
des décors de rue des activités des
moyens de se restaurer aussi à la
manière de l'époque alors prévoyez votre
meilleur costume Grégory si vous comptez
y aller ce week-end ça devrait passer
peut-être
médiéval plutôt médiéval avec peut-être
une armure à prévoir pour cette foire
médiévale pour les plus téméraires c'est
pas forcément mon cas il y a le musée
Maurice Denis qui propose une Murder
Party c'est samedi soir de quoi
sera-t-il question c'est ça le musée
vous propose d'enfiler cette fois votre
casquette de détective pour résoudre
tenez-vous bien une enquête criminelle
l'Escape Game vous plonge alors dans une
soirée tragique des années 1875 ou
l'autre de la soirée Charles bondoua va
subitement être assassiné et ça ça se
passe sous sans même du musée c'est ça
c'est ce qui rend l'expérience assez
impressionnante et immersive le jeu
prend place au sein même des salles
d'exposition dans un décor aménagé pour
l'occasion est-ce que c'est accessible à
tous alors pour vous pas de souci
Grégory en revanche c'est déconseillé
pour les moins de 15 ans un autre
événement à retenir peut-être ce
week-end pour terminer oui dans le cadre
de la Semaine du Goût samedi et dimanche
un parcours du goût est organisé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est ouvert au
grand public le salon donne lieu à un
concours culinaire qui est destiné à des
jeunes pris en charge dans le cadre de
la PJJ alors la PJJ c'est la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse l'objectif
Grégory ici c'est de favoriser
l'insertion de ces jeunes
[Musique]